[música]
เฮ
>> [música]
[música]
>> เฮ
เฮ
[música]
Olá,
pessoal, tudo bem? Boa noite. Estamos
iniciando o nosso penúltimo encontro de
revisão de direito civil paraa nossa
prova da OAB que acontece nesse domingo.
Hoje é dia de estudar obrigações,
não é isso? Hoje é dia de conversarmos
sobre direito das nossa senhora, direito
das obrigações. E eu quero mandar um
beijo muito especial para todo mundo que
tá aí ao vivo acompanhando a gente
agora. Comecei um pouquinho mais cedo,
mas não tem problema nenhum porque a
aula vai ficar disponível. Então, quem
chegar um pouquinho depois vai pegar o
nosso encontro normalmente. Meu Deus do
céu, o óculos tá imundo. Deixa eu tentar
limpar esse óculos melhor. Não tem um
paninho de óculos aqui. Manda esse link
aí pros seus amigos, tá podre, que
precisam estudar direito das obrigações.
É, já falamos de famílias, sucessões,
contratos, coisas, responsabilidade
civil e hoje vamos conversar sobre
obrigações.
Gente,
professora, que que a gente tem a falar
de obrigações, né? Que que eu tenho que
entender de obrigações? Eu já começo
trazendo para você aqui um ponto
interessante que eu já vou até botar
pronto para você, pra gente não ficar
perdendo tempo com a escrita, que é
o que que é o objeto da obrigação, né?
que que a gente efetivamente estuda com
direito obrigacional,
o que que a gente fala quando a gente tá
estudando direito obrigacional, que
também é chamado de direito de crédito,
direito de de direito pessoal, direito
de crédito, direito das obrigações.
E a gente sabe que é sempre uma relação
jurídica entre credor e devedor. Então,
qual é o objeto real estudado no direito
das obrigações? curte aqui hoje. Então,
falando de obrigações, a gente vai
observar que é uma relação jurídica
sempre entre credor e devedor [roncando]
e basicamente caracterizada
pela seguinte relação jurídica. A gente
tem aqui, ó, dentro da parte de
obrigações,
uma relação entre credor e devedor.
De onde surge essa relação? Pode ser de
um contrato, pode ser de um ato ilícito,
de um ato unilateral. Professora, me dá
exemplo. Vamos lá. Se eu celebro com
você um contrato de compra e venda, vai
surgir uma relação obrigacional entre
credor e devedor. Tá aqui, ó. Contrato.
Ato ilícito. João bateu o carro no carro
da Maria e o João foi ocupado. Surge uma
obrigação do João pagar a dívida. Isso é
um ato ilícito.
Um ato unilateral, por exemplo, como
quais são os atos unilaterais que nós
temos? Quem é que lembra quais são os
atos unilaterais?
Gestão de negócios.
Promessa
de recompensa.
Eu boto uma plaquinha lá. Perdi meu
cachorro. Porque encontrar o cachorro,
eu prometo dar uma recompensa de R$
5.000. Isso gera uma obrigação para quem
encontrar o cachorro receber R$ 5.000.
E enriquecimento sem causa.
Enriquecimento sem causa, que quando
alguém recebe além do que deveria ou no
lugar de quem deveria receber, gera um
enriquecimento sem causa. A pessoa tem
que devolver o que foi recebido, né?
Então, esses são os atos unilaterais que
também geram as obrigações. Direito das
obrigações, artigo 233 a 420,
divididos categoricamente nas seguintes
partes: modalidade das obrigações,
transmissão das obrigações, a de
implemento e extinção das obrigações e
na de implemento obrigacional.
E basicamente quando a gente fala de
obrigação, a gente tem que lembrar que é
uma relação jurídica.
É uma relação jurídica entre credor e
devedor. Credor, que é categoricamente
o sujeito ativo da relação obrigacional.
Vou tá aqui, ó, tá até aqui em cima.
sujeito ativo da relação obrigacional,
o sujeito passivo, que é o devedor.
Entre eles existe um vínculo que é o que
traz, né, a ligação jurídica entre
credor e devedor. E nós temos que esse
vínculo reflete uma prestação que é um
dar, um fazer ou um não fazer. Esses são
os elementos da relação obrigacional.
elemento subjetivo, credor e devedor.
Elemento objetivo, prestação. E o
elemento imaterial ou espiritual, que
corresponde ao vínculo. Agora,
uma coisa é uma coisa, outra coisa é
outra coisa.
Vou reiterar uma coisa que nós
conversamos
na no encontro de contratos, mas eu
gosto sempre de reiterar isso, porque
isso é sempre cobrado em prova e muitos
de vocês confundem. Uma coisa é uma
coisa, outra coisa é outra coisa
completamente diferente. Profe, como
assim? Vamos lá. Olha lá.
Um beijo aí paraa minha xá.
É minha xá. Robert.
Amo os desenhos da professora, sempre
perfeitinhos. Obrigada, viu? Obrigada.
Bom, vamos lá. Vamos conversar aqui
sobre uma coisa é uma coisa, outra coisa
é outra coisa.
obrigação.
Obrigação
é diferente
e muito diferente
de um direito real,
tá? Obrigação é muito
diferente
de um direito real.
Por quê? O direito obrigacional, ele é
caracterizado pela situação
de uma relação jurídica de sujeito com
sujeito.
O direito real não é uma relação
jurídica, é uma situação jurídica de um
sujeito
com uma coisa.
A gente já estudou direito real
e categoricamente o grande exemplo de
direito real chama-se propriedade.
Todo direito real está previsto no
artigo 1225
e esses direitos reais gravitam em torno
da propriedade.
O fato é que você pode criar uma
obrigação por meio de um contrato e esse
contrato ter por objeto um direito real.
É possível isso?
Imagina você que
o povo celebra um contrato.
Vamos fazer aqui um contrato. O povo
celebra um contrato
entre
João,
que é o vendedor
e
José
comprador.
Essas partes estão celebrando um
contrato
de compra e venda.
Tá? Essas partes estão celebrando o
contrato de compravenda.
Imagina que o valor da compra e venda
seja de R$ 100.000 R e o objeto da
compra e venda seja um carro.
O João tá vendendo o carro dele para o
José.
Vou até tirar isso aqui porque fica
parecendo que eu tô fracionando o
material.
Então, a gente tem aqui um contrato de
compra e venda do carro entre João e
José.
Imagina você que esse contrato
foi celebrado
dia 20/05. Presta atenção, dia 20/05.
E no dia 20/05
ocorre o pagamento
no mesmo dia.
No dia 20/05 acontece o pagamento.
O João se comprometeu a fazer a entrega
do carro
no dia 25/05.
Tudo bem? Temos três elementos
importantes aqui.
Minha pergunta é, primeira pergunta,
por que
José
já pagou?
Ele é o dono do carro?
Quem assistiu a aula passada sabe
responder. Porque o José já pagou. Ele é
o dono do carro. Que que você me diz?
Ele é o dono.
A resposta aqui é o quê?
Não.
Não. Por que, professora? Que é não?
Porque para ele ser o dono,
ele tem que ter a propriedade.
Embora exista o contrato,
embora exista o contrato entre as partes
aqui,
a propriedade
se transmite não com a assinatura do
contrato.
A propriedade do bem móvel
se transmite
com um fenômeno chamado
tradição,
que é a entrega.
A coisa imóvel
se transmite
com o registro no cartório de registro
de imóvel.
Então, uma coisa é a tradição, outra
coisa é a assinatura do contrato. Então,
ele porque ele pagou, ele é o dono, não.
Ele é o quê? Ele é
apenas
o credor
no recebimento do carro. Você entendeu
isso aqui? Ele é apenas o credor,
o credor no recebimento do carro. Ele
não é o dono ainda. Ele é apenas o
credor no recebimento do carro.
De modo que se
o João não entregar o carro,
que que acontece?
O José poderá exigir a entrega do carro.
Se o João fala: "Vou te entregar o carro
no dia 25, fique tranquilo".
E no dia 22 ele vende o carro para
Carlos.
Entregando o Carlo, o carro para Carlos.
A pergunta é: quem comprou, que nesse
caso aqui que eu tô dando de exemplo é o
José, ele pode reivindicar contra o
Carlos o carro? Não, porque eu só posso
reivindicar coisas nas quais eu seja o
dono e ele não é o dono. Por que que ele
não é o dono? Porque não chegamos no
momento da tradição.
Então, até a tradição, que é a entrega
do bem, quem é o dono? O dono é o
vendedor,
OK? O dono é o vendedor, certo?
Tudo bem? Então, uma coisa é o direito
real, outra coisa é o contrato. O
direito real, ele é aquele direito que
tá previsto no 1225.
O direito real, ele gravita em torno de
um fenômeno chamado propriedade.
E nós temos inúmeros direitos reais.
Aliás, quando a gente vai fazer, quando
a gente vai falar do direito de
propriedade,
que tá lá no 1228,
a gente já comentou dos atributos da
propriedade. Quais são os atributos da
propriedade? É o direito de quê? Usar,
gozar, dispor e reaver o bem. Então, é o
direito de usar,
gozar,
dispor
e reaver o bem,
tá? Então, os direitos reais gravitam em
torno de um fenômeno chamado
probriedade, que é o genuinamente
direito real. Mas nós temos inúmeros
outros, como uso, uso fruto, habitação,
hipoteca, penhor, anticrese, servidão,
superfície,
eh direito real do promitente comprador
do imóvel. Nós temos inúmeros direitos
reais, mas todos os outros gravitam em
torno da propriedade. A bem
para falar a verdade, todos os outros
decorrem de um fenômeno chamado direito
de propriedade. Tá bom? Belezura? Então,
segue o bonde se você quiser dar o print
nessa tela aqui.
Vamos lá.
em tempo. Ainda quero conversar com
você, já que nós estamos falando de
direito das obrigações,
eu quero dizer para você
que quando a gente fala de uma
obrigação,
presta atenção agora, isso aqui é
importante.
Quando a gente fala de uma obrigação,
eu celebro uma obrigação entre credor e
devedor, qual é a grande característica
da obrigação? Ela produz efeito inter
partes.
Tudo bem?
Já
o direito real,
já o direito real, que são esses que
gravitam em torno da propriedade,
eles possuem efeito
oponível contra todos, chamado de efeito
erga.
Homes, a ninguém é dada a dado o direito
de violar a propriedade dos outros e
quem quer que viole será demandado.
Então, a obrigação é ergar homenis.
Aliás, quando a gente fala a obrigação é
ergomes, não, a obrigação é interpartes.
Quando a gente fala que é interpartes,
é porque ela rola entre credor
e devedor. Não tem como um terceiro,
aliás, em tese, se meter no meio aqui.
Confere?
Confere. Então, beleza.
Dá uma olhada nesse caso de prova que eu
vou passar para você.
Imagina,
e você sabe que a banca gosta de
questões contextualizadas,
né, ali,
eh, situações hipotéticas para você
resolver.
Eu vou te passar situação hipotética
agora. Dá uma olhada aqui.
Eh, imagina você
que Maria
é proprietária.
Maria é proprietária
de uma casa.
Curte só essa parada aqui.
Aqueles meus desenhos bem do jardim de
infância, né?
Maria é proprietária dessa casa,
tá?
E a Maria resolve
alugar a casa. Ela faz, portanto, um
contrato de locação.
Locação,
alugando este imóvel
para o João.
Vai pegando aqui o detalhe.
E esse contrato tem a previsão
de vigência de 48 meses,
mediante o pagamento do aluguel mensal
de R$ 5.000,
tá? O pagamento do aluguel mensal de R$
5.000.
Então, Maria é proprietária,
locadora,
João é o possuidor
locatário.
Esse contrato tem vigência por 48 meses,
mediante o pagamento de aluguel de R$
5.000.
Tudo bem?
Conforme eu mencionei para você
agorinha, agorinha
quem é proprietário tem o quê?
O grud.
Falei isso para você agorinha. O que que
é o grude?
é o direito de gozar,
reaver,
usar e dispor.
Maria como proprietária tem esse grude,
que é o direito de gozar, reaver, usar e
dispor.
Nesse caso específico,
a Maria
tendo a propriedade, ela transferiu para
o João, e a gente já conversou isso aqui
na aula de posse, o direito de usar e
gozar do bem, mas ela continua tendo o
direito de reaver e dispor. Quando a
gente fala do direito de dispor, é o
direito que a Maria tem de vender o bem.
A minha pergunta é, Maria, no exercício
dela aqui
de proprietária,
presta atenção, Maria, no exercício dela
ela pode vender o bem? Que que você me
diz?
Ela pode vender o imóvel,
sim ou não?
Sim, sim,
sim. Ela pode vender o imóvel,
tranquilo.
Mas a primeira regra para ela vender o
imóvel
é observar o seguinte.
Lei do inquilinato, vai prestando
atenção,
lei 8245.
pela lei do inquilinato, o imóvel
alugado, se ele for colocado à venda,
então a gente já sabe que a locação não
impede a venda, a gente vai ter que dar
ao
João locatário o direito de quê? O
direito de o direito de
preferência. Então o João terá direito
de preferência, ou seja, a Maria deve
dar ao João
a possibilidade de comprar a coisa.
Artigo 27 da lei do Inclinato. Então a
gente tem que dar ao João direito
de
preferência, tá bom? Ela vai dar ao João
a possibilidade
de se manifestar
em 30 dias.
Em 30 dias.
Nesses 30 dias, o juiz, o juiz, ó, o
João pode dizer o sim e aceitar comprar
a coisa
ou o João pode falar não quero.
Se o João fala não quero preste atenção
agora. Se o João fala não quero
significa
que a Maria poderá então, portanto,
poderá
vender
para
outra pessoa.
Tudo bem? poderá vender para outra
pessoa. Aí a minha pergunta é: imagina
que a Maria
vende para essa pessoa que se chama
Antônio,
ou seja, o Antônio foi lá e efetivamente
comprou
a casa. O Antônio foi lá e efetivamente
comprou o imóvel.
Nesse caso,
olha a pergunta que eu vou fazer para
você.
O Antônio,
que é o comprador,
deve
respeitar
o
contrato
de locação
que tem com o João da casa?
Olha essa pergunta. Ele deve respeitar
o contrato de locação
que tem do João com a com a que tinha do
João com a Maria.
Sabe qual que é a resposta?
Tá no próprio material. Ora, se o
contrato gera uma obrigação e a
obrigação é interpartes, só produz
efeito entre Maria e João. O terceiro
adquirente não tem nada a ver com a
história. Então, não, não, o Antônio não
precisa respeitar esse contrato
de locação.
Não,
Roberta.
Então,
a regra
é que não.
E se o Antônio quiser tirar o João da
casa, ele vai promover uma ação
de despejo, como já orientou o STJ.
Eu nem concordo com a ação, mas já
orientou o STJ. Então, se ele quiser, se
o Antônio quiser tirar o João de lá, ele
pode tirar mediante uma ação de despejo.
Agora, qual que é a exceção?
é que sim, ele respeita,
mas ele só vai respeitar,
só vai respeitar
se esse contrato de locação, que
genuinamente produz efeito interpartes,
em algum momento tiver efeito ergais.
E como que eu atribuiria o efeito
ergais?
por meio do registro, no cartório de
registro de imóvel, onde tá registrado
esse imóvel,
atribuindo eficácia ergais, que é o
artigo 576
do Código Civil. Então, quando você faz
um contrato de locação, ninguém registra
contrato de locação.
Mas se você quiser atribuir à aquela
locação um efeito ergais oponível a
qualquer um, oponível a todos, você
deverá registrar esse contrato no
cartório de registro de imóvel. Então,
via de regra para eu a, aliás, via de
regra, as obrigações produzem efeitos
apenas o quê? interpartes. Mas se eu
quiser fazer uma obrigação, produzir
efeito ergais, eu faço desde que a gente
promova o registro desse contrato de
locação. Tudo bem?
Certo.
Dá o print nessa tela aí. Tema bacana,
né?
Tá bom.
Vamos lá, vamos para uma outra situação,
gente. Quando um devedor não paga a
obrigação,
quando o devedor não paga a obrigação, o
que que o credor faz?
Me conte. Quando a criatura
devedora não paga obrigação,
que que o credor faz? Cobra.
Mas para cobrar eu tenho que respeitar
um prazo, porque nem toda dívida, nem
toda obrigação pode ser cobrada a
qualquer tempo.
Eu tenho que o quê? Eu tenho que
respeitar prazo. Vamos lá no material.
Olha lá.
Olha
isso aqui.
Quando
o devedor,
o devedor
não paga
a sua dívida decorrente de um contrato
ou decorrente de alguma obrigação.
O credor
deverá
cobrar
básico.
Quando a gente fala do credor
cobrando o devedor,
tem um prazo
e esse prazo é
de pres
crição.
Olha o macete.
Toda vez que o credor
quer cobrar o devedor, o prazo é de
prescrição.
Todo prazo prescricional,
todo prazo pressional está previsto em
lei.
Memoriza isso.
Basicamente
em dois artigos.
e
206.
O artigo 205
prevê o prazo prescricional
de 10 anos,
que é uma cláusula prescricional máxima
geral para tudo que não tiver prazo no
206, que são casos específicos
de 1, 2, 3, 4 e 5 anos.
Então, o artigo 206, ele tem aqui os
parágrafos. Parágrafo primeiro, prazo de
1 ano. Parágrafo segundo, 2 anos.
Parágrafo terceiro, 3 anos. Parágrafo 4
anos. Parágrafo 5to 5 anos. Se o caso
que você tá discutindo, como por exemplo
o que a gente já falou, responsabilidade
civil extra contratual, não tiver
previsão no artigo 205,
deixa eu botar uma almofadinha aqui, a
gente vai trabalhar como sendo um prazo
de 10 anos, tá?
Dica que eu te dou.
2 anos,
alimentos,
3 anos,
aluguel,
enriquecimento sem causa,
responsabilidade civil aquiliana ou
extra contratual,
reparação civil,
tá? 5 anos, dívidas líquidas.
previstas em instrumento,
mas o fato é que eu tenho que cumprir o
prazo.
Só que
vem uma pergunta,
vem uma pergunta.
Olha
a pergunta.
Existem dívidas
que não
podem
ser cobradas.
Dívidas que não podem ser cobradas são
dívidas que você tem credor, tem
devedor, tem prestação, tem o objeto da
prestação, mas elas não podem ser
cobradas.
Dívidas que não podem ser cobradas
são chamadas
de obrigações naturais.
Exemplo,
exemplo,
dívida de jogo,
jogo proibido ou tolerado, porque se o
jogo é permitido, eu posso cobrar, né?
Se a lei permite o jogo funcionar, é
porque eu posso cobrar.
Jogo proibido, tolerado,
dívida prescrita,
né? Jogo proibido, tolerado, dívida
prescrita, são as chamadas obrigações
naturais.
Agora imagina
que tem uma dívida prescrita,
né? Ou seja, o credor não pode mais
cobrar. exemplo, ele tinha 3 anos para
cobrar, não cobrou em 3 anos. Não cobrou
em 3 anos. A dívida é uma dívida
prescrita.
Nesse caso,
se o devedor voluntariamente paga a
dívida prescrita, olha, você me devia R$
2.000, eu tinha 3 anos para te cobrar,
não cobrei.
Aí você foi lá depois de 4 anos e pagou
a dívida.
Será que você pode pedir de volta o que
você pagou,
alegando que não sabia se tratar de uma
dívida prescrita?
Por exemplo, eu apostei no pôker com
você e perdi.
Não sabendo que você não pode me cobrar
dívida de jogo,
eu vou lá e te pago voluntariamente.
Depois eu chego para você e falo assim:
"Ah, eu não devia ter feito efetuado o
pagamento porque a dívida de jogo eu não
sou obrigada a pagar. Eu posso te cobrar
de volta o que eu paguei? Que que você
me diz?
Cuidado.
São dívidas que não podem ser
efetivamente
cobradas,
mas elas existem,
só não podem ser cobradas.
Então,
se o devedor
pagar
voluntariamente,
se o devedor pagar voluntariamente,
voluntariamente mente
não
poderá,
não poderá
pedir
de volta
o que pagou.
Sabe por quê?
Porque
o credor
tem
o direito
de
reter o pagamento.
Perfeito.
Show de bola.
Então isso aqui, gente, [roncando] é
tipo muito sensacional.
Imagina que cai na sua prova uma regra
dessa.
João apostou no pôker com José. O João
perdeu. O José cobrou. O João pagou.
Depois o João descobre que não precisava
ter efetuado o pagamento porque a dívida
de jogo e dívida de jogo não se pode
cobrar. Poderá ele pedir de volta o que
pagou? Não. Porque muito embora a
obrigação natural não possa ser cobrada,
é uma obrigação que existe. E por ser
uma obrigação que existe, ela deve ser
cumprida. É uma obrigação natural.
Porque uma coisa é a obrigação existir.
Uma coisa é a obrigação ser existente
entre credor e devedor. Outra coisa é o
credor poder cobrar essa obrigação. Para
cobrar a obrigação é preciso que se
respeite o prazo prescricional.
Tudo bem? Maravigold.
Maravigold.
Vamos para uma outra coisa. Vamos para
uma outra questão. Olha só. Dá o print
aí nessa tela.
Imagina você
que o João, gente, questão de prova aqui
total, tá? Imagina você, deixa eu ligar
esse ar aqui porque eu tô cozinhando
aqui dentro na mortandade. Vamos lá.
Imagina você que o João
emprestou
R$ 50.000
para Maria.
Dinheiro é coisa fungível, né? Então,
qual é o nome desse contrato? Bom, João
é credor,
o nome desse contrato
é múo, que é o empréstimo de coisa
fungível. Se fosse coisa infungível, o
nome seria comodado.
E
Maria
é a devedora.
Imagina você
que
o pagamento
teria que ter acontecido
no dia 25
do 4
de 2025.
O pagamento
por esta obrigação deveria ter sido no
dia 25/04/2025.
E aí a Maria falou:
"João, não tenho dinheiro,
né? Maria falou: "Não tenho dinheiro".
E pensando nisso, presta atenção agora.
A Maria chega, vou fazer uma linha reta
aqui para ocupar menos espaço.
A Maria chega e fala assim: "João, como
eu tô na merda e não tenho dinheiro,
eu quero oferecer
a você.
Um carro,
um carro que inclusive vale R$ 55.000,
um pouco mais do que eu te devo
no lugar
do dinheiro.
Entendeu a obrigação?
Deixa eu te falar,
a cereja do bolo aqui.
Cereja do bolo, que o mais importante
não é o bolo, é a cereja do bolo.
Cereja do bolo aqui é você responder pra
minha seguinte pergunta.
E você sabe,
o João
é obrigado
a aceitar.
Que que você me diz?
O João é obrigado a aceitar o carro.
Gente, faz parte,
faz parte, né?
faz parte do direito obrigacional. É
muito comum, não tenho dinheiro para te
pagar, mas eu tenho uma coisa para te
dar, um relógio, o carro, um brinco.
Você aceita no lugar? Que que você me
diz? O João é obrigado
a aceitar prestação diversa?
Ele é obrigado a aceitar prestação
diversa.
Roberta, obrigado. Obrigado é demais,
né?
Obrigado é demais.
Ele não é obrigado, mas se ele quiser,
ele pode. A gente tem uma regra de ouro
aqui no direito obrigacional, tá? A
gente tem uma regra de ouro.
Professora, que regra de ouro é essa?
Vou até subir meu ouro mais aqui.
Que regra de ouro é essa? Vamos lá.
Qual é a regra de ouro?
é que o credor,
o credor
não
é obrigado
aceitar
prestação.
diversa
da que
lhe é
devida. Ele não é obrigado a aceitar
prestação diversa da devida, ainda que
mais valiosa.
Ainda que mais, vou botar assim, ó.
Ainda que mais valiosa.
Ele não é. Qual é a palavrinha de ouro
aqui?
Ele não é.
Obrigado,
professora.
Mas se ele quiser,
ele pode. Pode. Se ele quiser, ele pode.
E aí, gente, se ele quiser, a gente vai
ter
duas situações interessantes.
Duas situações interessantes. Olha que
interessante.
Dois nominhos diferentes para vocês.
Se ele quiser, ele não é obrigado.
Mas se quiser,
ele pode.
E aí nós podemos ter duas situações
diferentes.
Que porcaria de desenho ridículo esse
meu, hein?
Vamos abrir um pouquinho para ficar mais
gordinho.
Se ele quiser, ele pode. E se ele
quiser, podemos ter duas situações.
que ele simplesmente
só
aceitar
sem fazer mais nada,
terá
acabado de acontecer
um fenômeno chamado
dação
em
pagamento.
Então, se o cara
simplesmente
só aceita o carro, fala: "Não, Maria, tá
bom, beleza, vou aceitar o carro,
tchau".
É uma dação em pagamento,
tá? Agora, se ele fala assim: "Não,
Maria, vamos fazer o seguinte, vamos
extinguir essa obrigação anterior, vamos
extinguir essa obrigação anterior e
vamos criar uma nova,
uma nova com uma nova obrigação de
entregar o carro.
Aí ele tá
gerando
a exinção
da obrigação anterior e criando
uma nova obrigação.
Nesse caso,
o que estará acontecendo
é a chamada
novação obrigacional,
na verdade uma nova objetiva,
porque nova é a extinção da obrigação
anterior e criação de uma nova. Eu posso
gerar a extinção da obrigação anterior e
criando uma nova com novo objeto,
novação objetiva, ou gerar a extinção da
obrigação anterior, criando uma nova com
um novo sujeito. Novação o quê?
Subjetiva. Tá tudo bem?
Beleza.
Maravigode.
Mas professora, ele faz o mesmo pelo
mesmo?
É
tranquilo. Crio uma nova obrigação com
um novo objeto. Beleza.
Por que ele faria isso? Não sei.
Colocando uma multa diferente, sei lá,
uma cláusula diferente.
Tá bom?
Dá o print nessa tela.
Vamos trabalhar
o mesmo caso.
Vou pegar esse mesmo caso aqui.
Mesmo caso.
Imagina você que o João emprestou 50.000
para Maria.
E em troca
o João falou: "Maria,
eu vou te emprestar
esse dinheiro,
mas eu quero de você
uma garantia.
Eu quero que você me dê uma garantia."
Aí a Maria vai lá. Vocês já viram o
relógio mais caro do mundo?
Ele é ridiculamente feio.
Ridiculamente feio. Vou abrir aqui.
É um relógio
que sangue do Cristo tem poder.
Eu não sei se ele é o mais caro do
mundo, mas é muito caro.
É esse, é esse relógio aqui, gente, que
meu Deus do céu, Jesus misericordioso.
me desse,
eu usava.
Mas
olha que coisa mais ridícula.
Olha o preço desse relógio.
Esse relógio dá nem para enxergar a hora
aqui, né?
Ele é o relógio mais caro do mundo. Foi
criado em 2014
de diamantes. Esse aqui é menos feio,
né? Esse esse é até bonitinho.
Imagina que ela pega e entrega um
relógio desse. Brega, ridículo,
horroroso em garantia.
Relógio horroroso em garantia.
Foi lá e falou: "Não, meu amigo, me
empresta esse dinheiro que eu te entrego
aqui um relógio em garantia. R$ 50.000
ela deu em garantia o relógio.
Olha aqui,
deu em garantia o relógio. Se ela deu em
garantia uma coisa móvel,
qual é o nome dessa garantia?
Qual o nome dessa garantia?
Povo falando que ia vender desmontado.
Penhor.
Quando eu dou um bem móvel em garantia,
eu estou indo fazer um penhor, né? E ela
deu esse relógio. Eu tenho duas
perguntas para te fazer.
Duas perguntas
do coração.
Duas perguntas do coração. A primeira,
vamos lá.
Sei. O
se, né?
Se a
Maria
não pagar.
João, que é o credor,
poderá
ficar
com
o relógio.
Ele poderá ficar com o relógio para ele,
sim ou não? Isso aqui já caiu em prova.
Ele pode ficar com o relógio para ele.
Que que você me diz? Resposta: não. Por
que que não? Porque existe a vedação.
Vamos botar bonitinho, né?
é vedado
o pacto
comissório.
Pacto comissório é o pacto
que permitiria
o credor
a ficar com o bem dado em garantia.
Aliás, se tiver uma cláusula dessa, ela
é completamente nula. Então é nulo o
pacto comissório, ele tem que levar para
leilão,
tem que levar para leilão, não pode
ficar com o bem, tá?
Um outro o um outro ponto,
uma outra pergunta. Imagina
que a Maria fala: "Ai, João, tô bed,
muito bed, porque assim, cara, eu te dei
o relógio em garantia,
mas esse relógio ele é muito importante
pra minha família, muito importante
mesmo. Ele é um relógio assim de
família.
Meu vô morreu e o sonho da vida dele era
ser enterrado com esse relógio.
Aí que que você faz numa situação dessa?
Descobre onde é o velório do velho para
tu ir lá e pegar o relógio, né, gente?
Porque
é a solução da vida, né?
Então o que que a gente tem aqui?
Se
Maria
devolver Maria não, João.
o João
devolver
o relógio, só pra Maria enterrar o velho
para Maria.
Tá vendo que tudo é questão de prova?
antes
de
ocorrer
o pagamento
significa
que
Maria
perdoa
a dívida inteira. Que que você me diz?
Sim ou não? Claro que não.
Claro que não.
Claro que não,
né? Não. Que que significa? Significa
que ele tá abrindo mão apenas da
garantia. Ele não tá perdoando a dívida.
Então, quando o credor devolve para o
devedor a coisa dada em garantia antes
de vencer a obrigação, significa apenas
e tão somente que ele tá renunciando à
garantia. Nada mais que isso. Então, vou
voltar lá. Não, não
significa
apenas
que
renuncia
a
garantia.
Significa apenas que ele está
renunciando
à garantia. Tudo bem?
OK.
Marav gold, né? Marav gold. Me dá um
segundo.
Bebe água.
O meu nem é água, é coquinha.
Vamos lá, professora. Deixa eu dar o
print nessa tela. Foi muito que bem. Dá
o print nessa tela.
Dá o print nessa tela.
Pronto.
Dá uma olhada aqui agora.
Imagina você
que eu tenho.
Vamos lá.
Agora é um ponto de dúvida de muita
gente.
Muita e muita gente. Curte só isso aqui.
Eu tenho um credor
e um devedor.
Eu tenho um credor e um devedor.
Não vou botar assim mesmo.
Se esse credor,
se esse credor
deve, aliás, se esse devedor
deve
R$ 1.000, R. Como que ele cumpre a
obrigação?
Entregando R$ 1.000.
Se esse devedor
deve o cavalo, como que ele cumpre a
obrigação?
Entregando o cavalo.
Você concorda que dinheiro é divisível e
o cavalo é indivisível?
Beleza? Se você só tem um credor e um
devedor, não importa se é divisível ou
não. O devedor tem que cumprir a
obrigação. Ponto.
Ponto. Ele tem que cumprir a obrigação.
Agora
vamos lá.
Se eu tenho,
olha a merda agora.
Se eu tenho
um credor
e três devedores.
ou se eu tenho
três credores
e um devedor.
Vamos lá.
Credor, devedores, credores, devedor.
Eu tenho, no primeiro caso,
um
credor, um devedor laranja,
um credor laranja,
um menino aqui verde
e um aqui azul.
Vamos lá.
Se eu tenho vários devedores
devendo,
nesse caso aqui,
R$ 3.000,
como que eles vão cumprir a obrigação?
R$ 3.000 é divisível ou indivisível?
Divisível.
Se eu tenho uma obrigação divisível,
como que o devedor cumpre a obrigação?
entregando a cota dele. Quanto que o
azul vai pagar? 1000.
Quanto que o verde vai pagar?
1000. Quanto que o laranja vai pagar?
1000. Cada um é responsável
pela sua respectiva
cota.
Agora, se o devedor deve R$ 3.000
a três credores,
continua sendo divisível.
Ele vai pagar quanto pro laranja?
1000.
Ele vai pagar quanto pro verde?
1000. Ele vai pagar quanto pro azul?
1000.
Mais uma vez, cada um é responsável pela
sua cota.
Agora, você não pode meter solidariedade
onde não tem.
Você não pode meter solidariedade onde
não tem.
Solidariedade
não se presume.
decorre de quê?
Decorre da lei
ou
da vontade das partes.
Ficou feio, né?
Botar aqui, ó.
decorre da lei
ou vontade das partes. Quando a gente
fala de solidariedade,
a gente tá falando de uma regra que não
importa se o bem é divisível ou
indivisível.
Nós vamos ter
todos
pelo
todo,
todos pelo todo. Então, se eu devo
dinheiro, como nesses dois exemplos aqui
que a gente deu, que eu vou copiar aqui,
se eu tenho uma dívida de dinheiro,
a gente trabalha com a questão
das respectivas cotas, né? cada um ali
pela sua respectiva cota. Agora, se eu
tenho solidariedade,
é todo mundo pelo todo mundo.
Imagina que nesses dois exemplos a
dívida seja de R$ 3.000.
O credor,
nesse primeiro caso, não havendo
solidariedade,
ele só pode exigir de cada um a
respectiva cota.
E nesse caso, cada credor só pode exigir
a sua cota.
Nesse exemplo aqui da solidariedade,
se eu tenho vários devedores
em, opa, em solidariedade
com esse credor,
o credor pode exigir o todo de qualquer
devedor. Isso aqui é solidariedade
passiva.
Então esse credor, ele pode cobrar
R$ 3.000 do laranja?
Pode, pode. Ele pode cobrar os 3.000 do
laranja? Pode. Se ele cobra 3.000 do
laranja, significa que ele renunciou à
herança. Ô, a herança. Que que eu tô
falando de Já tô doida? Significa que
ele renunciou à solidariedade.
Que que você me diz? Significa isso?
Não, ele só escolheu de quem ele quer,
de quem ele quer
ajuizar
a ação
de quem ele quer cobrar.
Entendeu? Entenderam isso?
Roberta, e se esse credor ajuizar ação
contra o devedor laranja?
Se ele ajuizar ação contra o laranja,
ele renunciou o verde ou azul? Não, não,
não.
E lá no processo civil, o que que você
aprende?
O devedor, o credor, ajuizou ação só
contra o laranja. Que que o laranja pode
fazer?
chamamento
ao
processo dos outros devedores.
Então, o que que cai em prova?
Cai em prova
exatamente isso. Se o D foi acionado
para pagar os 3.000, não tem problema.
Ele pode chamar o verde e o azul. E
mais, se ele paga,
ele vai cobrar as cotas.
Ele vai cobrar quanto do azul? R$ 1.000.
Quanto do verde?
R$ 1.000.
Certo,
professora? E nesse segundo caso,
nesse segundo caso aqui, se eu tenho
pluralidade de credores e um devedor que
deve R$ 3.000,
se não houver solidariedade,
cada credor só pode exigir sua cota.
Mas se houver solidariedade,
o devedor, ele pode pagar tudo para quem
ele quiser.
Ele pode pagar tudo para o verde, pode.
Ele pode pagar os 3.000 pro verde, pode.
Nesse caso aqui, se não houver
solidariedade e ele paga 3.000 pro
verde, ele tá pagando errado.
E quem paga mal paga duas vezes.
Quem paga mal paga duas vezes. Agora,
havendo solidariedade,
os credores autorizam que qualquer um
deles receba o todo. Imagina que o verde
recebeu todo. Aí ele vai ter que fazer o
quê? Repassar 1000 pro azul
e repassar
1000 pro laranja.
Então, a grande sacada da solidariedade
é a confiança da solidariedade ativa,
né, que é esse caso aqui, ó.
Solidariedade ativa é a confiança.
Tudo bem?
Certo.
Roberta, e se algum dos credores morre?
Os herdeiros em conjunto
podem representar, coloquei os herdeiros
em conjunto podem eh representar
o credor ou devedor solidário.
OK?
Beleza. Vamos lá. Vamos lá.
Mais uma coisa importante. Dá o print
nessa tela aí.
Mais uma coisa importante.
Imagina você
que a gente tem aqui
uma obrigação,
tá?
Boa noite pro povo do Recife, que eu
amo, minha terra maravilhosa.
Imagina o seguinte,
somente se responde nos limites da
herança, né? Porque os herdeiros não são
obrigados a pagar a dívida do morto.
Vamos lá. Imagina você
que eu tenho uma obrigação
entre João
e Maria.
Tá.
João
credor, Maria devedor. João credor,
Maria devedor. Duas, dois exemplos de
obrigação.
Maria deve aqui pro João 50.000.
Aqui também mesma mesmo exemplo, 50.000.
A minha pergunta é, primeira pergunta, o
João
pode
ceder
o crédito
para alguém? Vamos botar para Antônio.
Sim ou não?
Resposta:
sim.
Ele pode chegar pro Antônio e falar:
"Antônio, vou transferir para você o
direito de receber 50.000 pela do
dinheiro eh do da Maria, da devedora
Maria. Você pode receber aí no meu
lugar, beleza? Beleza?
Ele pode fazer então, portanto, o que
chamamos de
sessão
de
crédito,
certo?
E aí, se ele faz essa sessão de crédito,
sai o João e entra quem?
O Antônio, sacou? Sai o João e entra o
Antônio.
Gente,
a Maria é a devedora.
A obrigação da Maria é pagar a dívida
para quem? para quem é o credor.
Então, eu posso, como credora de alguém
ceder o crédito que eu tenho para
receber para outra pessoa?
Sim ou não? Sim, claro. Tranquilo.
Então, eu tenho uma sessão de sessão de
crédito.
Minha pergunta é: ceder o crédito,
Maria?
Deve
autorizar.
Obrigada, Emanuel.
Maria deve autorizar.
Não. Autorizar não. Não, porque ela já
tá na merda. Ela tem que pagar para quem
é certo.
Maria tem que ser o quê?
Avisada, notificada para ela pagar pra
pessoa certa.
Então, na sestão de crédito, o devedor
não tem que consentir.
OK?
Agora imagina o oposto.
Maria
pode
ceder
a dívida dela
para Antônio?
Sim ou não?
Saindo
a Maria e entrando o Antônio no lugar
dele. Pode? A resposta também é sim.
Pode, o nome disso
é sessão
de
dívida,
sessão de dívida
também chamada de
assunção
de dívida.
Só que veja bem, a situação aqui já muda
um pouco de figura. Eu tô cedendo a
dívida,
o devedor original vai sair, vai entrar
outro no lugar.
E se eu estiver querendo colocar uma
pessoinha
insolvente, eu ia falar insalubre,
insolvente na relação [roncando]
obrigacional.
E se eu tiver querendo colocar uma
pessoa insolvente na relação
obrigacional?
Insolvente é aquele que não tem
patrimônio para pagar a dívida.
Nesse caso, na assunção de dívida,
vem a pergunta:
"O João
deve
autorizar?"
A resposta aqui é
sim.
Aqui ele tem que autorizar,
tá vendo?
Aqui ele tem que autorizar
porque o devedor original ele só pode
sair,
ele só pode sair se houver autorização
daquele credor. Se não houver
autorização daquele credor, nada feito,
não pode sair, entendeu? Então, se cair
na sua prova
sessão de crédito,
tem que ter autorização do devedor, não.
Sessão de dívida, assunção de dívida. O
devedor saindo e colocando outra pessoa
no lugar dele. Tem que ter autorização.
Sim, tem que ter autorização.
Certo?
Tudo bem?
Vamos dar o print nas telinhas de hoje.
Muito maravig.
Hoje a gente conversou sobre obrigações.
Olha o tanto de coisa que a gente falou
de direito obrigacional.
Olha lá, falamos aqui da relação
jurídica.
Sempre, gente, a obrigação, ela tem uma
relação jurídica patrimonial, tá?
Falamos aqui
que uma coisa é direito obrigacional,
outra coisa é direito real,
porque uma coisa é uma coisa, outra
coisa é outra coisa. completamente
diferente.
Nem sempre,
aliás, nem sempre não, a simples
assinatura de um contrato não te torna
não te torna ali eh
obrigado, né,
a a obrigado, não, não te torna
proprietário, perdão, não te torna
proprietário,
tá?
Para você ser proprietário da coisa,
você tem que consolidar o direito real.
Consolidar o direito real. Consolidar o
direito real é sendo bem móvel com a
tradição e móvel com o registro.
Falamos aqui que mesmo um imóvel
alugado, ele pode ser vendido,
mas quando o imóvel é alugado
e o proprietário quer vender, ele tem
que dar o direito de preferência ao
locatário, tá na lei do inquilinato. E
ele tem que dar ali 30 dias para ele
exercer se quer ou não comprar.
Se ele quiser comprar, vende para ele.
Se ele não quiser comprar,
aí aí nós vamos ter o quê? Se ele não
quiser comprar, nós vamos poder vender
paraa terceira pessoa. A terceira pessoa
não é obrigada a respeitar o contrato de
locação e pode despejar o locatário, a
não ser que aquele contrato de locação
tenha sido registrado. Aí o comprador
tem que respeitar.
Falamos também sobre prazo prescricional
e obrigação natural.
O devedor que paga voluntariamente
uma obrigação,
ele não pode pedir de volta o que ele
pagou, mesmo se tratando de obrigação
natural, que é a obrigação que você não
pode se cobrar mais. Por quê? Porque o
credor tem o direito de reter o
pagamento.
Também conversamos que o credor não é
obrigado a aceitar prestação diversa da
que lhe é devida,
mas se ele quiser aceitar, ele pode
aceitar.
E se ele aceita simplesmente por
aceitar, será uma dação em pagamento. Se
ele aceita
extinguindo a obrigação anterior e
criando uma nova, chama-se novação
objetiva.
Sempre que você tem a extinção de uma
obrigação anterior e a criação de uma
obrigação nova, chama-se novação.
Falamos também que ao realizar um
contrato, o devedor pode dar um bem em
garantia. Só para você lembrar um ponto
interessante. Quando o devedor entrega
um bem imóvel em garantia, nós estamos
falando de uma hipoteca. Quando ele
entrega um bem móvel em garantia, nós
estamos falando de um penor.
Navios e aeronaves, muito embora sejam
bens, negócio, como é o nome? Móve
navios e aeronaves, mesmo sendo bens
móveis, quando dados em garantia, a
garantia é chamada de hipoteca.
E aí, nesse caso, a devedora deu um
relógio em garantia. Dando o relógio em
garantia, a gente tem um penhor. Fizemos
duas perguntas.
Se a Maria não pagar a dívida, o João,
que é o credor, pode ficar com o relógio
para ele ser dono do relógio? Claro que
não. Não pode. E se tiver uma cláusula
no contrato autorizando ele a isso, essa
cláusula é nula. Isso aqui já caiu em
prova.
Se o João devolver o relógio paraa
Maria, que é a devedora antes do
pagamento, significa que a Maria, não,
botei errado aqui, significa que João,
bem que alguém tava falando no chat,
acho que era a Alana
que eu tinha colocado errado e eu não
prestei atenção. Se o o João perdoa a
dívida? Claro que não. Significa apenas
que ela que ele renunciou à garantia.
Tá? Conversamos em tempo ainda das
obrigações divisíveis e solidárias.
O devedor solidário, nesse caso aqui,
que acionar,
nesse caso aqui, ó, que acion que for
acionado judicialmente,
significa que o credor renunciou
os demais devedores. Não, significa que
ele escolheu quem ele quer cobrar e quem
foi demandado poderá promover o
chamamento ao processo. Gente,
chamamento ao processo não é
obrigatório,
tá?
Se for solidariedade ativa,
qualquer credor pode receber o todo
integral do devedor.
Se não houver solidariedade, só posso
receber em cotas. E a gente terminou
dizendo que
sendo sessão de crédito, o devedor é só
avisado, notificado,
para que em relação a ele a sessão possa
produzir os seus efeitos.
Em sendo uma sessão de dívida,
o novo devedor, que é chamado de
assuntor, somente pode entrar no lugar
do devedor anterior, se houver
autorização do nosso credor, para evitar
que eh a o devedor anterior coloque um
novo devedor completamente insolvente
nessa parada de sucesso. Tudo bem?
Passou rápido, né? Pois muito que bem.
Pegue o bonde. Estamos juntos.
Sexta-feira, nosso último encontro com a
parte geral. E não esqueça, o caminho é
um só.
Seguir
é o que te faz alcançar.
Só não passa no exame de ordem quem
desiste.
E depois que você passar lá no seu
registro, na OAB, da sua seccional de
escolha, não vai constar se você passou
de primeira, de segunda, de terceira, de
quinta, de 10ª, de 20ª,
nada.
Sua advocacia não depende disso. Amo
muito vocês. Fiquem bem.
Estamos juntos. Reta final é pesada, é
difícil,
dói
porque é muito solitário o caminho.
A gente fica cheio de incertezas,
bate a desesperança.
Mas vou te contar uma coisa.
Sangue no olho.
Sangue no olho. Respira, ergue a cabeça,
enche o peito e vai.
Porque tem dia que a nossa única
alternativa
é essa. Na verdade, muitas vezes a gente
não precisa nem ser forte,
é só a gente seguir,
porque seguir é a nossa única opção.
Então, já que tem que seguir, vamos
seguir feliz, né? Vamos seguir sendo
resiliente, esperançoso,
porque eu tenho certeza que vai dar
certo, tá bom?
Sexta, temos o encontro marcado, acho
que é 10 ou é 11 horas da manhã, não me
recordo, aqui no canal do grão AB.
Sábado temos a nossa revisão de véspera.
Domingo temos nosso gabarito pós prova
às 17 horas em Poin aqui no canal do
grão AB, que é um canal muito feliz e
alegre feito especialmente para você e a
sua aprovação, tá bom? Beijo, beijo,
beijo. Qualquer coisa tô aqui no
YouTube, no canal Direito Como nunca se
viu e lá no Instagram @roakeiroz.
Beijo, Brasil. Boa noite para vocês. Até
a próxima.
[música]
Ah.